a una semana de las elecciones que mal
calix dar Blue celebró uno de sus
mítines más multitudinarios hasta la
fecha y mantienen una sólida posición
para hacerse con las riendas del poder
político en Turquía y posiblemente gane
a una segunda vuelta contra el actual
presidente reyeta allí Perdón
quiero que sepan que abordaremos los
problemas de todos no discriminaré de
ningún modo abrazaré a los 85 millones
de turcos independientemente del partido
la identidad o las creencias
alguna vez pareció impensable que Eduard
pudiera ser derrocado del poder en la
presidencia desde 2014 y Primer Ministro
durante la década anterior la crisis
económica
erosionado su popularidad han pasado
años y mira cómo está el país la gente
ni siquiera puede permitirse beber té ya
no es como antes durante la campaña
electoral ha reconocido el estrés
económico del pueblo Turco afirmando que
solo él puede lograr el crecimiento del
país
compensaremos estas pérdidas económicas
con todas las mejoras que hemos
introducido en los salarios de nuestros
empleados y jubilados además de la mala
situación económica el gobierno ha
recibido críticas tras los dos
terremotos masivos de febrero en los que
murieron más de 50.000 personas el 14 de
mayo también está en juego los escaños
parlamentarios y los expertos políticos
afirman que hay mucho sobre la mesa no
solo quien dirigirá a Turquía sino Qué
papel desempeñará en la escena mundial